Public Sénat France 24 et RFI
[Musique]
présent bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'Europe nous sommes
ensemble sur France 24 et radio Fance
internationale en cette semaine
d'assemblée générale de l'ONU où les
leaders mondiaux ont présenté leur
analyse nous allons développer la vision
proprement européenne de la marche du
monde et nous rejoignons en effet en
duplex depuis New York le chef de la
diplomatie de l'Union européenne le Haut
représentant Joseph Borel bonjour
monsieur Borel je rappelle que vous êtes
aussi ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères de Pedro Sanchez jusqu'en
2019 donc de sensibilité
social-démocrate on le comprend j'ai
envie de vous demander d'abord ce que
vous retenez de cette semaine
d'assemblée finalement à New York
c'était un
marathon dominé sans doute par la la
guerre contre l'Ukraine et l'émergence
d'un nouveau monde un nouveau monde avec
des pays que il y a 50 ans n'existait
pas où il avait peu d'importance et que
maintenant demande sa place dans les
institutions
internationale et puis le discours du
secrétaire général en advertissant au
monde des grand dangers que nous faisons
face et les grand problèm que c'est
l'inégalité l'inégalité à l'intérieur
des sociétés entre des pays les
objectifs de développement soutenable
sont loin d'être atteints et les besoins
de coopérer plus dans un monde qui est
chaque fois plus
confrontationnel d'ailleurs il y a eu
aussi évidemment la présence de
volodimir Zelenski après 18 mois de
combat pour l'Ukraine il veut
remobiliser l'opinion publique
américaine occidentale et même du Sud
est-ce qu'il a réussi pour vous
l'exercice vous savez il y a dans le
monde de pays que oui il vote contre la
Russie aux Nations Unies mais qui ne
partage pas les sentiment d'indignation
morale que nous avons vis-à-vis de cette
guerre d'agression de la Russie contre
de l'Ukraine qui voit ça comme un
problème entre européenne qu'ils ont
peur que l'effort que nous faisons en
faveur de l'Ukraine puisse dévier des
ressources dont ils ont besoin aussi
mais alors justement il y a une grosse
fâcherie entre trois pays la Pologne la
Slovaquie la Hongrie au sein de l'Union
européenne qui veulent continuer à
interdire l'importation de ces céréales
qui passent sur leur sol et qui et bien
font chuter les prix pour leurs AG
culteur dit-il
disIl monsieur zelansk qui veut les
traîner devant l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce comment ça va se finir la
commission s'en occupe mes collègues de
la commission qui s'occupent des
affaires de marché de et de commerce
sont en train de voir de quelle manière
trouver une solution à cette discussion
qui ne doit pas nous éloigner du
problème
fondamental le problème fondamentale la
question fondamentale c'est que la
Russie bloque les exportations des
grains de l'Ukraine
pas seulement bloque mais elle détruit
elle bombarde elle brûle le stock des
grains et les infrastructures
nécessaires pour l'exporter et en ainsi
faisant elle est en train de créer un
grave problème alimentaire au monde si
ça ne s passait pas les problème de
l'effet des exploortations ukrainiennes
vis-à-vis de la Pologne ne se poserait
pas non plus il y a un problème
fondamental il a un pays qui bloque des
millions de tonnes de céréales qui sont
absolument nécessaire pour
l'alimentation du
monde on sait quand même qu'il y a des
élections importantes hein pour le parti
au pouvoir droit et justice en Pologne
le 15 octobre donc bientôt et que leur
base est très rurale mais en attendant
quand même est-ce que ça vous inquiète
pas que le premier ministre monsieur
moravi qui a dit qu'il ne livrait plus
d'armes à l'Ukraine est-ce que on est en
train de diviser les Européens sur la
question de la Défense et de l'armement
la position de l'Union européenne reste
la même le président du Conseil européen
président char Michel l'a dit bien
clairement au Conseil de sécurité
nousunion européenne nous continuons à
aider l'Ukraine tant qu'il lu faudra
avec les moyens que les États-membres
ensemble et à travers de nous à travers
de l'Union et chacun de son côté met à
disposition de l'Ukraine et grâce à ça
l'Ukraine a pu résister s'il y a des
problèmes même que je considère
conenturel et transitoire on va les
résoudre mais l'aide de l'Europe à
l'Ukraine continue plein vent vous avez
d'ailleurs annoncé un conseil des
ministres des Affaires étrangères qui se
tiendrait bientôt à Kiev est-ce que vous
croyez pouvoir réunir les 27 ministres
des Affaires étrangères justement là-bas
et pourquoi faire j'espère j'espère que
tous mes collègues vont aller à Kief
d'ailleurs ils ont tous demandé que ces
conseils tiennentle d'abord c une valeur
symbolique que les ministres toute
l'Europe des Affaires étrangères se
réunissent à kif aillent en Ukraine
c'est une façon de montrer cette aide
dont je vous parler et ensuite c'est
aussi la façon de discuter avec
l'Ukraine de quelle façon nous faisons
face au problème de qu'on dit en anglais
accountability c'est-à-dire demande
exigence de responsabilité à à la Russie
par les crimes de guerre qu'ils sont
commus de quelle façon de le faire on va
discuter de ça et aussi de notre
engagement euh à moyen long terme avec
la sécurité d'Ukraine pas seulement
fournir des armes pour les combats qui
ont lieu maintenant et que espérons
qu'il vont finir tôt mais de quelle
façon une fois que la guerre sera finie
l'Europe va continuer à assurer
l'Ukraine et la meilleure façon de
garantir la sécurité ukrainienne c'est
que l'Ukraine devient membre de l'Union
européenne alors les leader des 27 pays
as l'ont décider et il faut mettre ça en
pratique sur l'élargissement de
l'Ukraine la Moldavie les Balcans des
pays de l'Est sont favorables hein pour
tous ces pays assez vite mais la France
et l'Allemagne veut mettre en place ce
fameux groupe des1 qui propose un
certain nombre de réforme nécessair à
l'élargissement la généralisation d'un
vote à majorité qualifié pour faire
passer plus facilement un certain nombre
de textes ou encore des sanctions plus
fortes si on ne respecte pas l'état de
droit est-ce qu'il faut réformer l'Union
européenne pour l'élargir oui oui il le
faut moi je pense qu'il le faut et mon
expérience me les me le dit clairement
je vois pas comment on pourrait
continuer à décider à l'unanimité pas 27
c'est déjà très difficile parfois mais à
37 on fonctionne pas de la même manière
quand on est 6 qui r tené 40 et les
élargissements successives ont fait que
la méthode de décision soit de plus en
plus grippé oui les pays candidats à
l'adhésion doivent faire beaucoup de
réformes pour être prêt c'est un
processus basé dans les mérites mais
nous aussi il faut qu'on prépare nos
procédures interne pour faire face à une
vous savez la la quantité détermine à la
fin la méthode il faut le faire je salue
les propositions faites par par
l'Allemagne et la France alors revenons
quand même sur cette assemblée de l'ONU
pas si général que ça à New York quatre
des cinq membres permanents du Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies brille par
leur absence vous interprétezv comment
l'absence d'un Emmanuel Macron à l'ONU
ne croit plus au rôle de cette
assemblée non bien sûr que non je suis
convaincu que la France considère les
Nations unies comme un instrument
fondamental de la vie en commun nous
vivons de plus en plus dans un monde
multipolaire et paradoxalement on est
dans un monde de moins en moins
multilatéral et c'est bizarre parce que
plus il y a des pôles plus on a besoin
d' multilatéralité pour faire que cet
ensemble de pôles puisse fonctionner
ensemble les règles RG du jeu doivent
être plus précises une fois que le
nombre de joueurs
augmente mais la réalité du monde montre
que nous vivons dans une multiporalité
diffuse
complexe fluide où il y a pas des
alignement il y a pas un pouvoir
hégémonique il y a des pouvoirs qui se
bloquent et se complémentent monde
beaucoup plus complexe ou il faut
inventer des nouvelles méthodes de
nouvelles façons de faire que cette mul
complicité d'acteurs puissent interagir
d'une façon efficace à travers d'un
nouveau multilatéralisme alors parlons
de ce conflit qui inquiète quand même
les Européens dans le haut karabak mardi
l'armée azerbaïjanaise a lancé une
opération militaire dans cette région
sécessionniste majoritairement peuplé
d'Arméniens que Bakou et Evran se
disputent depuis des décennies est-ce
que vous craignez un un embrasement
après cet épisode sanglant il faut faire
tout pour éviter il faut tout pour
éviter que c cette action militaire que
l'Union européenne condamne parce que
nous condamnons l'usage de la force pour
régler les problèmes puiss s'étendre
dans un nouveau conflit entre l'Arménie
et l'Azerbaidjan et certainement nous
faisons responsable l'azerbaayan de la
sorte de population civile au kabach
qu'elle soit pas déplacer des forces
qu'il y ait pas des activités ou des
actitudes qui touchent la dimension
nique de ces populations nous saluons le
haut le feu et nous ferons tout ce que
nous pouvons pour fournir de l'aide
humanitaire et évidemment si si
commençit avoir des activités contre les
population civiles l'Union européenne
devrait réagir est-ce que justement et
on appelle à les deux parties à la
retenue estce que pour éviter que les
chos devienne pire alors la leader donc
de de l'Italie Georgia méonu qui est
issu de la droite radicale mais l'imig
imigration a mis l'immigration au centre
des débats Ursula van derleen était à
l'île de Lampedusa le 17 septembre pour
annoncer une aide et un plan donc
logistique et Georgia moloni a
critiqué l'attitude de l'opposition de
la gauche italienne sur sur le grand
accord bilatéral avec la la Tunisie UE
Tunisie et puis votre attitude à sou à
vous aussi Joseph
Borel qui finalement trouvait que cette
cette
démarches bilatéral n'était peut-être
pas tout à fait équilibré justifié vous
répondez quoi non écoutez euh d'abord il
faut montrer toute solidarité avec
l'Italie dans un moment difficile on
peut pas faire face à une arrivée
massive des milliers de personnes sur
une île que qui compte moins d'habitants
que des migrants donc l'Union européenne
sera au côté de l'Italie et ce que la
présidente de la commission a fait avec
son voyage c'est montrer cette aide et
essayer de voir de quelle manière cette
aide c'est quelque chose de plus que des
mots et ceci dit l'immigration a des des
raisons profondes à des causes profondes
il faut s'attaquer aux causes profondes
de
l'immigration évidemment il faut
contrôler les frontières les frontières
sont là pour quelque chose et les États
ont le devoir de les contrôler et il
faut faire les tri entre les gens qui
ont droit àacile et leur donner Cees
droit et les gens qui sont des migr gens
disons économi qui n'ont pas ne peuvent
pas demander un asile parce que ils sont
pas dans une situation de demandeur
d'asile et à mon avis il faut trouver
une politique qui aille au-delà dans un
moyen terme des mesures strictement
sécuritaire pour établir avec les pays
d'origine et des transit des accords qui
permettent de recevoir d'une façon
régulière une immigration régulière dont
nous avons besoin et en même temps
qu'ils acceptent leur plutô des migrants
qui mettent en péril sa vie pour rien
parce que s n'ont pas les droit de être
accepté dans dans nos pays ne pourront
pas l'être et ça c'est un travail de
longue haleine il y a pas de des
solutions miraculeuses évidemment il
faut aider à ces pays à surveiller ses
frontières mais la scur la solution
simplement sécuritaire ça peut résoudre
des problèmes dans le court terme dans
des moments de crise
mais ça ne remplace pas une solution qui
passe pour l'aide à l' dévement et et ça
c'est très important à la bonne
gouvernance parce qu'il y a des pays
riches en Afrique riches en ressources
qui sont pauvres parce qu'ils ont été
sous le la cou de régime soit militaire
soit dictatoriel qui ont profité des
richeres des pays au détriment de ses
habitants en fait madame mélonie dans
cet accord finalement avec la Tunisie
qui se voulait exemplaire regrette
surtout l'absence de versement de fonds
européens à Tunis qui pense que et pense
que c'est pour cette raison que
finalement il y a afflu à Lampedusa une
partie de cet accord c'était une aide
financière à la Tunisie pour renforcer
ces ces capacités de contrôle des
frontières si cette quantités n'ont pas
été déversé franchement je me sens pas
responsable parce que j'ai pas de
capacités budgétaire euh lors d'une
conférence à New York vous avez exprimé
votre pleine solidarité avec Paris alors
que l'ambassadeur français au Niger est
sous le coup d'une expulsion des
pchistes et en ce qui concerne
effectivement sa multiplication des des
PCH au Sahel et bien l'Union européenne
devrait réévaluer selon vous sa
stratégie
elle est en échec flagrant vous trouvez
écoutez on peut pas dire que ça soit un
succès depuis que je suis à Bruxelles
malheureusement l'ensemble de coups
d'État se sont suivis l'un après les
autres on voit la présence russe AUG
Moné notre présence influence diminuée
mais il faut pas s'autoflagéer non plus
il faut pas se sentir responsable de
d'une réalité qui touche
fondamentalement la au pays en question
et surtout il faut faire il faut pas
faire du du du French bashing il faut
pas mettre à la France comme la la
responsable de cette situation la France
a employé beaucoup de ressources
matérieles l'humain a mis des morts et
de l'argent pour aider parce que on lui
a demandé de venir à l'aide du Mali
c'est ça qu'elle a fait et maintenant
c'est il faut montrer solidarité avec la
France en particulier avec son
ambassadeur et aussi avec le présidents
deessus par le coup d'État militaire il
faut appeler un chat un chat ça c'est un
coup d'état même s'il y a quelqu'un qui
ne veul pas l'appeler de cette façon et
je rends hommage je rends hommage à
président Bazou un homme intègre qui
avait en tête un projet de modernisation
du nigerre en commençant par la la la
donner aux femmes la capacité de
développer sa vie sans être obligé à
devenir des des des maires tout de suite
à 14 ans dans un cadre d'une croissance
démographique
enc impossible de de soutenir
économiquement et il faudra être à côté
du président bazoua qui on considère le
le président légitime de Niger c'est ça
qu' la français et c'est pour ça que que
l'ambassadeur français est assiégé merci
Joseph Borel pour cette interview vous
restez bien sûr sur notre antenne nous
continuons sur le thème des relations
compliquées entre l'Union européenne et
l'Afrique puisque c'est le thème de
notre débat à Bruxelles avec des députés
européens et
[Musique]
public merci de nous rejoindre au
Parlement européen à Strasbourg l'Union
européenne s'inquiète du du futur de son
continent miroir l'Afrique Joseph Borel
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
affirme même qu'il faut revoir en
profondeur notre politique alors que
l'influence de la Chine et de la Russie
ne cesse de grandir sur tous les plans
sur ce continent économique militaire
politique après le Mali le Niger le
Gabon d'autres s'interrogent sur la
multiplication des coup d'État dans
l'Afrique francophone alors que l'Union
européenne s'est engagé à soutenir la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamique au
Sahel 2 ans après avoir été finalisé par
les négociateurs le traité qui régit les
relations entre l'Union européenne et
les 89 membres de la communauté des pays
d'Afrique des Caraïbes et du Pacifique
vient enfin d'être ratifié mais la
lenteur un des 27 pour mettre en œuvre
cet accord laisse un gouamer au
partenaires africains qui voit un signe
de la méfiance des Européens la
Commission européenne quant à elle
multiplie les accords bilatéraux portant
un intérêt particulier sur les question
migratoire mais quel message singulier
l'Union européenne peut-elle porter sur
le continent africain en 2023 peut-on
enfin espérer une relation apaisée et
équilibrée alors pour en débattre
aujourd'hui deux eurodéputés Assita
Kanko eurodéputé Belg des conservateurs
et réformistes bonjour et Max Orville
eurodéputé français renw Europe
d'ailleurs le dernier événement tragique
en date le terrible tremblement de terre
au Maroc illustre un peu les malentendus
entre les deux rives de la Méditerranée
le Maroc accepte l'aide de l'Espagne
mais pas celle de la France ancienne
puissante coloniale avec une diplomatie
qui qui lui déplaî l'Union en tant que
telle n'est pas d'ailleurs perçu comme
un
continent bon moi je pense que sur cette
question il faut d'abord s'incliner
devant le drame qui dont tu as été
frappé le Maroc la seconde chose c'est
que c'est c'est voilà la priorité c'est
euh pas de savoir est-ce que le Maroc
État souverain va accepter euh l'aide de
la France la France est disponible
l'Union européenne l' également la
France va participer d'une manière ou
d'une autre à l'aide pour le Maroc et je
crois que c'est ça le message essentiel
alors sur le plan sécuritaire he l'Union
européenne elle voulait investir dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme au Sahel avec
pour leader en la matière la France
maises résultats aujourd'hu our les
coups d'État ils se multiplient au Mali
au Niger au Gabon au Burkina Faso dont
votre famille est originaire je vous
propose d'abord d'écouter aussi la VAN
derlen à ce
sujet la succession des coups d'État
militaires augmentera l'instabilité dans
la région pour les années à venir la
Russie exerce une influence sur le chaos
qui règne elle en tire également profit
la région est devenue un terra fertile
pour le terrorisme ces événements
concernent directement l'Europe pour
notre sécurité pour notre prospérité
nous devons donc faire
preuve de la même unité d'intention à
l'égard de l'Afrique que celle que nous
avons montré pour l'Ukraine c'est une
obligation nous devons nous concentrer
sur la coopération avec les
gouvernements légitimes et les
organisations régionales il nous faut
développer un partenariat mutuellement
bénéfique axé sur des problématiques
communes à l'Europe et à
l'Afrique une réaction d'abord au Sonor
d'Ursa VL qui qui qui parle en effet de
coup d'états militaires successifs et
puis de ce partenariat qu'il faut
relancer entre l'Europe et l'Afrique oui
en fait il n'y a rien de nouveau dans ce
que la présidente fondelen a dit
aujourd'hui dans dans son discours sur
l'état de l'Union et donc en gros nous
sommes assis dans un contexte où on
court après les faits donc en réalité la
situation euh dans la en Afrique de
l'Ouest donc dans la région du Sael est
géopolitique ce n'est elle est pas
seulement régionale et il est clair que
ce n'est pas seulement la région qui
perd c'est aussi l'Union européenne en
terme d'influence dans un monde
multilatéral où la Russie est en train
de gagner du terrain et la Chine aussi
et au niveau de l'Union européenne la
plus grande réforme de la diplomatie
européenne serait quelqu'un d'autre pour
faire le travail de Borel le travail
qu'il ne fait pas vous trouvez c'est un
peu un peu dur pour le chef de la
diplomatie est-ce qu'il est pour quelque
chose est-ce que finalement l'Union
européenne paye pas justement une les
anciennes puissances coloniales la
France la Belgique peut-être aussi et ce
et qui pénalise l'image de l'Europe tout
entière aussi non je je suis un petit
peu plus mesuré les coups d'État
africain c'est quand même les États
africains qui qui ont décidé les les
coups d'État sont faits par les
militaires je ne crois pas que l'Union
européenne soit coupable même si on peut
déplorer que Wagner qui est pour moi la
définition du
désordre contribue
largement privé r bien évidem bien
évidemment donc je crois que l'Union
européenne doit délivrer son message qui
est un message d'humanisme qui est un
message d'aide de disponibilité on ne
peut pas dire d'un côté c'est toujours
la faute des puissances coloniales et et
donc non moi ça me dérange l'Union
européenne a un message et elle doit le
conserver je ve repréciser mon propos
parce que quand je dis que c'est un
problème géopolitique j'inse sur le fait
que ce n'est pas un problème africain et
je ne dis pas que c'est l'Europe qui
doit résoudre le problème des coups
d'État ceci concerne plus que des coups
d'État c'est quoi la situation en
Afrique deux éléments premièrement nous
n'avons pas réformé la coopération au
développement et la manière dont
l'Europe gère sa stratégie avec
l'Afrique nous sommes restés dans les
années 60 dans les années 70 avec une
politique qui euh qui qui bébicite
l'Afrique une politique qui finance la
dictature une dictature dont les
Africains ne peuvent se défaire en
général qu'à travers des coups d'État
moi j'ai grandi au Burkina Faso j'ai vu
des des gens danser dans la rue quand
j'avais 7 ans en 1987 quand a eu le
premier coup d'État que j'ai vu et toute
une série d'autres coups d'états après
en gros c'est le seul moyen pour
certaines populations de changer de
président et c'est quand même un drame
et pourquoi un dictateur peut tenir
aussi longtemps ils utilisent beaucoup
l'argent de la coopération pour financer
leur dictature donc il faut qu'on revoit
la manière dont on on travaille avec
l'Afrique deuxièmement il faut qu'on
sache que l'islamisme qui a gagné du
terrain dans des pays qui étaient
laïques il y a pas si longtemps que ça
est un malâ qui nous guettete aussi tout
comme il nous a guetté quand il a
commencé en Syrie on a vu
qu'alqïda le le le Boko Haram daesh se
regroupe dans la région on a averti euh
Borel on a averti le Parlement les
institutions européennes depuis 2019-
2020 mais qu'est-ce qui a été fait on a
continué c'est pas une solution oui
c'est ce que je voudrais dire à la
collègue la France est venu à la demande
pay elle été la seule effectivement je
suis d'accord que la France a été toute
seule à prendre les choses au sériux
consé les conséqu c'est que
aujourd'hui les coups d'État les
populations on entend un sentiment très
pro français donc français an
antifançais pardon donc c'est pas lieu
au coup d'État c'est lieu à la
propagande russe et c'est lieu au fait
que on n'a pas réformé la coopération au
développement pendant tout ce tempsl
alors parlons de la s'il vous plaît de
la la coopération parce que sur le
terrain économique et commercial l'Union
européenne elle perd du terrain par
rapport à la Chine et la Russie mais il
y a quand même ce global getateway le
portail mondial he qui prévoit notamment
des investissements de 150 milliards
d'euros en Afrique sur 6 ans est-ce que
ça c'est une bonne façon de relancer la
relation économique avec le continent
africain je le pense je crois queous non
je crois qu'effectivement l'Europe reste
toujours le premier contributeur même
s'il y a d'autres concurrents comme la
Chine ou comme euh la Russie maintenant
l'Union européenne nous sommes
tributaires de ce que nous portons nous
portons des valeurs et donc pour nous la
fin ne justifie pas les moyens je crois
que la relation sur cette base là de du
Global Gateway nous devons établir avec
l'Afrique une
relation partenariale gagnant gagnant et
il ne s'agit pas de refaire de la de la
centraafrique comme je dirais ou de la
francafrique des années 7080 pas du tout
il s'agit d'avoir en face de nous aussi
des États africains adeptes de la
démocratie qui vont promouvoir moi je
milite pour ça une l'éducation et avec
un véritable partenariat avec les les
pays africains ce qui nous frappe là
aujourd'hui c'est coup d'État outre le
fait que bon vous disiez tout à l'heure
chaque fois qu'on est qu'il y a un coup
d'état on voit la population dans la rue
ce sont toujours les militaires qui s'en
par du pouvoir et qui ne le rendent pas
naturellement aux autorités civiles
dernièrement j'entendais pour le
Gabon une transition annoncé de 2 ans où
les militaires garderaient le pouvoir
donc qu'on fasse partir le président
pour l'avoir suspecté de fraude et
cetera d'accord mais il y avait un
opposant et il y avait des élections qui
pourrai être faites donc l'Afrique doit
aussi se prendre en main et l'Union
l'Union européenne doit poursuivre son
travail de valorisation de nos valeurs
c'est ce que comment dirais-je le disait
dans son discours la présidente de la
commission l'Europe c'est la sécurité
bien sûr mais c'est aussi la solidarité
et il faut trouver cet équilibre mais
alors justement quand vous parliez de
babyitting finalement de l'Afrique on
comprend on comprend que forcément
l'idée que l'Union européenne est le
premier donateur en Afrique avec un fond
de développement de 30 milliards d'euros
ces 7p dernières années par exemple
c'est Don ce ce ce fonctionnement
développement ça vous paraît une une
réponse adéquate pour développer une
relation équilibrée ou est-ce que c'est
là que le bablesse en matière de
peut-être justement babiciting comm oui
c'est là c'est là surtout que le
baabaise parce que en fait euh il y a
une mentalité euh comme ça et c'est ce
que la gauche applique aussi en Europe
dans les quartiers difficiles hein que
ce soit en Belgique en France ou au
Pays-Bas c'est que il suffit de donner
un peu d'argent quelques subsides il
suffit de donner un chèque mais on peut
pas c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas
avec global get hein mais ça ça ça ça
c'est de l'investissement oui ça ça
fonctionnera s'il y a d'autres
changements aussi au niveau des des du
mindset de la mentalité profonde qu'il y
a dans la relation entre l'Europe et
l'Afrique en l'Europe ce sont des pays
c'est un continent c'est une union en
Afrique c'est aussi aujourd'hui dans le
discours vous ça vous aura peut-être
frappé qu'on a parlé de l'Afrique comme
si c'était un pays donc en gros hier
enfin chaque fois qu'on a un débat au
Parlement européen ça a été le cas en
2022 avant le sommet europeafrique on
c'est un peu tabou de parler de la de la
de la révision de la manière dont on
collabore avec l'Afrique je donne un
exemple concret quand les entreprises
veulent travailler avec des entreprises
africaines euh je prends des pays en
Afrique de l'Ouest par exemple c'est
extrêmement difficile vous allez chez
cofas en France vous allez chez credendo
en Belgique ou au au en Grande-Bretagne
c'est extrêmement difficile de d'avoir
les documents comptbl qu'il faut pour
couvrir la transaction entre certaines
entreprises européennes et des
entreprises sur place moi je trouve que
investir dans des négociation qui
permettront d'avoir une bonne centrale
des bilan c'est déjà c'est c'est pas de
l'argent qu'on a donné mais c'est une
procédure qu'on a changé et ça va faire
évolu et je l'ai vu quand je travaillais
dans le secteur privé que c'était un
frein au développement des PME au niveau
local et la manière le style les mots
qu'on utilise ça donne un complexe
d'infériorité et si on veut que les
enfants de l'Afrique demain se
prenent AF différemment aujourd'hui non
pas infantiliser les Africains non moi
je je pense que la coopération Union
européenne Afrique outre ce qu'on fait
déjà avec le programme global Gateway ça
serait effectivement peut-être la
création d'une Agence européenne de
l'éducation qui travaillerait de manière
partenariale avec l'Afrique parce que je
crois que non pas uniquement au niveau
financier mais comme vous le dites au
niveau éducation je suis porterit quel
message je suis mais je pense que il
faut aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
au Niger c'est le renversement d'une
démocratie d'un président légalement et
démocratiquement élu qui a été renversé
par une jeunte et c'est cette succession
de coup d'état c'est toujours des
actions militaires mais l'Union
européenne elle va peut-être apparaître
ce momentl comme donne de leç arriv mais
pas du tout parce que ce que je veux
dire NON NON cette agence européenne de
l'éducation serait basée sur un un duo
c'est-à-dire que qu'est-ce que on
demanderait à nos partenaires africains
quelle éducation vous voulez mettre en
place je prends un exemple j'ai organisé
ici un collocque sur l'éducation et il y
avait de nombreux pays africains la Côte
d'Ivoire le Rwanda le Sénégal et cetera
et que nous disait-il comment améliorer
cette éducation pour faire de nos
enfants africains des partenaires des
des citoyens éclairés pour que demain la
relation soit effectivement pense que
sur l'éducation vous serez d'accord en
revanche quand on voit la présidente de
la Commission européenne multiplier les
déplacements en Afrique au côté
d'ailleurs de la trait droitière Georgia
Meloni comme en Tunisie et cetera pour
signer des partenariats stratégique dont
le volet principal c'est quand même le
blocage de l'immigration sur le sol
est-ce que ce troc là il est totalement
légitime moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec euh alors je vais laisser madame
moi je pense que la première chose dont
on a besoin pour pour évoluer en tant
qu'être humain c'est d'être en sécurité
aujourd'hui si le Global le le l'index
global de la sécurité dit que le Sael
est l'épicentre du terrorisme dans le
monde ça doit nous amener à nous poser
des questions beaucoup plus sérieuses en
fait que euh euh des questions de
bureaucratie parce que aujourd'hui c'est
pas c'est pas en continuant à faire ce
que l'Europe pas toujours fait et on a
bien constaté que ça n'a pas encore
fonctionné depuis plus de 40 ans ça n'a
pas fonctionné et donc pourquoi
continuons-nous à faire ce que nous
avons fait et pourquoi on ne se met pas
on ne sort pas de notre zone de confort
pourquoi on dit pas on a commis des
erreurs et pourquoi on continue de
signer des chèqus en blanc dans le monde
en 2021 le chef de la diplomatie
européenne Joseph Borel a lui-même dit
nous avons peut-être signé trop de chèqu
en blanc moi je pense que la première
action c'est de ranger le chéquier et de
sortir accord de partenariat stratégique
avec un volet un volet euh euh
migratoire ça c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant ou peut-être réaliste
pragmatique je crois oui moi je crois
que euh la présidente de la commission
l'a dit dans son discours sur l'état de
l'Union nous avons à avoir deux chosees
assurer la sécurité de l'Europe ça c'est
clair mais nous avons également un
devoir de solidarité nous ne pouvons pas
accepter effectivement les morts dans la
Méditerranée nous avons euh j'allais pas
dire créer le droit d'asile en Europe
mais c'est une valeur à laquelle nous
tenons donc arriver à avoir ce ce ce duo
équilibré
alors un duo équilibré dont dont nous
reparlerons
mais on n est pas encore tout à fait à
vous écouter tous les deux merci en tout
cas d'avoir participé à ce débat merci à
nos téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivi
sur France 24 et sur Public Sénat vous
restez sur nos antennes pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]